you you drop out of school at what 15
yeah 14 15. 14 15. yeah like ninth grade
is the first year last year I finished
freshman year what was happening in
school
it was less school it's more like out of
kind of a [__] up situation at home um
I say that gently like we parents were
they're not like like in the grand
scheme of things it was fine yeah but it
was like I was the one who I'd like tell
my dad like Dad mom's cheating on you oh
really and like you saw what happened it
was yeah it was like
like I had to tell my father that and
that's [__] weird and tough yeah and
then my mother you know my mother really
like blamed the kids in a very like
classic like after school special like
Hallmark movie kind of way which was
just [__] up and then I just like we
all kind of did but my sister had a car
then my older brother was just in
college dean was little three years
younger than me and I was just sort of
like this weird stuck teenager so it was
just like full Rebellion you were acting
out in school yeah rebelling against her
Rebellion it's everything like I started
like selling weed really good yeah
because I remember like I discovered
weed this is a fun little
parenthetical here a little tangent for
us but I like first time I smoked weed I
was like yeah it's a lot of fun
I was like well let me get this straight
like a [__] paper route all week long
for like a [__] this much I was like
this is like not cost effective yeah and
then I remember we like all chipped in
and we got a half an ounce
and I was like you know mine was gone by
Wednesday yeah and my boy was like
mine's gone too but I got more money I'm
buying one I had to get more money I got
sold half of mine I was like how much
how much you sell it for and he's like I
sold it for 50. I was like but you only
chipped in 50 and he's like yeah but and
I was like oh and I started like doing
the math and I started yeah yeah yeah
start doing the math and I'm like okay
so you're telling me
if I buy a half a pound I can get a
sixteen hundred percent return on that
if I'm selling you that's really good
math for a Dropout yeah and that's what
I did and I was just [__] making bank
and how I did is like the house we lived
in everybody slept on the second floor
my bedroom was on the first floor oh so
you were free so they had a pager so
they Park a block away okay all right
this is old school drug dealers
I opened my window this is like cranking
the window to my parents house like they
come up the window and be like
they're like yeah it was good and then
like you got the eighth I was like yeah
like I remember I always show them the
scale
because you're doing it from the crib
yeah from my bedroom out the window like
McDonald's
after you drop it
like my parents
[Laughter]
like they're [__] my dad like I'm the
poor guy man that's a great guy my
mother [__] like [__] up [__] in
the house nobody's paying attention like
operation
but anyway that was one of the ways I
was acting out yeah and like I had some
degree of Financial Freedom because like
you know I had like a under the water
bed was hella loot like I was good and
um and then just got in a lot of trouble
at school like a lot of fighting a lot
of fighting like to this day like these
are all teeth scars on my Knuckles from
like really
are you pretty good no I was just like I
got picked on I was like a little kid
who's [__] weird looking I got into a
lot of fist fights like kids would pick
on me but like kids would like people
like beat me for weed like I'd give them
the weed they wouldn't give me the money
like you got you got two choices when
that happens you shut it down
or you're like the guy that people can
steal from so you have to shut it down
to shut it down and I was little but you
had to learn how to fight and I can
fight so you're [__] people up in
Connecticut or what I mean it was like
it's a stretch you're like talking about
kids who've barely hit puberty like
fighting in the backyard in the back
parking lots
Alex is seven and four and like eight of
those fights are all in the backyard
puberty yeah
and then like finally like I got in a
lot of trouble in school like something
really bad happened can you talk about I
think it was either a fight or when they
caught me smoking weed in the bathroom
and it was like a 10-day suspension and
it was also like you're like
five suspensions or 30 detentions and
you get thrown out of school I had 29
detentions at that point in time it was
like my sixth suspension and I just
remember my mom being like
um either you live by my rules or you
get out of this house and I remember
just like
like I know what you're like I know what
you're doing yeah you can't tell like if
it was my dad saying that it would have
been like I remember my dad when he gave
me the drug talk and he found out like
me and my friends tried acid once like
to this day I've done acid once when I
was like 13 and after my dad talked to
me about it it was such an effective
talk oh wow he was like you know you're
you know you know my friend I'm changing
the guy's name for his you know my
friend Chris and I was like yeah and
he's like you know how he is and I was
like yeah and he's like after he
graduated high school he spent the whole
summer doing acid in the basement and
that's why he's like that and I was like
I will never and like that's good that
was like solid but it was like coming
from her at that moment and I was like
fine I'm out but you respect you respect
your dad a lot yeah yeah and like I was
like I'm out and I like I remember I had
like a hardcover book under the water
bed like under the bubble that was
filled up with money so keep it flat and
it was like nine or ten thousand dollars
I just like shoved in my pocket took my
box fan if I can't sleep without like a
fan on me yeah and I just walked out
like walked out and like walked down the
street it's like a teenager just like
left like nine o'clock at night on a
Monday no cost no self nothing yeah
nothing so where you go you go see I
went to like I remember his name was
Ethan this kid
down the End of the Street there were a
couple of things like this kid and I
like called him from a payphone I was
like can I stay with you and he was like
hippie parents like yeah I can come
sleep over and I stayed at his house for
two nights and like there was this other
kid Dan who he also sold a lot of weed
and his mother used to like steal his
weed she didn't give a [__] and I was
like can I stay with you he's like yes
and I stayed with him for a few days and
then I met these two girls who were like
18 they had their own apartment oh [__]
now you can stay with us no drug dealing
and you gotta chipping on rent and I was
like I got money
and I was like I guess I should stop
doing drugs anyways I think moved in
with them so you risked two 18 year old
girls to the point where they just let
you move in yeah and then like 30
seconds later one of them was pregnant
[Laughter]
um at that time I was like I was 15 yeah
and she was 18. yeah that's good at home
yeah what was it what was like your
personal Reflections
[Music]
okay so so you're sleeping with one of
them yeah does the other one know does
she hear it in the night just [__]
like I mean I was like 15 that sound
never happened
it was like you know a second sometimes
a glance
[Applause]
your dick was a booster board
it was like was that it you know like
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
that like no I like I did we had a great
relation like I liked her yeah she was
awesome she was cool she was like it was
really independent strong-willed girl
whose parents had like like she she had
been on her own since she was young too
oh wow and she was just like a g she
worked hard she's like I had a job then
washing dishes because I wasn't doing
drugs anymore she was like driving to
work every day and like you know we
didn't know she was pregnant and me but
like you can you know you can start at
the end and then work back yes and I'm
not joking when I say like it was within
weeks now now meeting each other was
that was that was that like tricky to
get to that point did you hit on her
like were you like oh yeah this is
awesome how do you cross that threshold
because you're homeless yeah so you're
already grateful yeah and then you've
been in your landlord yeah that's pretty
impressive what is that like I don't
know
that's pretty awesome I haven't thought
in those terms in a long time because
it's like she uniquely doesn't like she
represents like my son's mother and this
woman that I've had this fantastic
relationship with for 26 years now she's
this wonderful person that I know so
I've never really thought of her in
those terms because like she was this
like hot teenager and I was this kid for
like this much of them and then for this
much of her life we're just like adults
together sharing this responsibility
being parents so I never get to think in
those terms but like you know back then
it was like you're a teenager you're
just learning about girls or like hot
girls in high school was that your first
time having sex no but it was you know
it wasn't far from that it wasn't far
from that I wasn't sure like it wasn't
yeah like it was very the first time
having sex to pregnancy it was it was
closed but it wasn't the first time okay
um you know there were like some fun
parties where like silly [__] happens
before that but like there was no I was
not by any means experience
I had to move you out I didn't know I
didn't know what was going on like
looking back at it like in the immediate
aftermath like when she was pregnant
like how did this happen I was like oh
no I definitely know how this happened
yeah right like you realize like this is
like not to take it from this fun bro
conversation to get real but it's like
the importance of sex ed I am dead
[__] serious right now they need to
teach kids I had no clue that you didn't
know where babies came yeah I knew where
babies came from but it was like
[Music]
I was a kid like none of it made sense
to me like I was just a kid like
obviously when you when I'm in my 20s
and I'm single it's all very Vivid and
yes but like young people have sex
without any understanding of what the
actual consequences are you thought the
pull out method was like 100 oh 100 and
I would pull out after I finished
like I didn't none of it
yeah I I understood I understood none of
it and it like it they teach you in sex
ed that's the most fun it's like I
didn't get to that class
like Connecticut public school education
we had like you know like one day a year
dedicated towards sex ed and it sounds
silly but like the time frame from like
kissing girls being like yo I got to
touch her boobs like that point in your
immaturity and your relationship with
women to me literally having a
girlfriend mine be pregnant that was
like we're talking about months you know
it's not a long time and like I wasn't
dumb I just had no idea and that part I
remember like I mean that's more like
reflecting back as a parent and as a
mature adult like I remember as I
entered my 20s in New York City and I
was actually single and I started like a
normal life with girls and dating and
sex and [__] like that it was obviously
like super clear how things work but for
that like short window of time and I
know like a lot of people that were like
around my age and mine like [__] up
part of the world who like also got
girls pregnant and either had kids or
students were clarified to explain
parents are terrible I'm terrified to
talk to my daughters about it my wife is
like a hero about it yeah how did you
feel when she told you were you scared
in that moment yeah
weirdly like no
um and I look back at that and like much
credit to her she's really like an
exceptional human being she's a very
strong super smart like tough
independent woman
um but she was terrified and I remember
like one time she was crying and I was
like why are you crying I was like we're
gonna have a kid this is gonna be fine
and like looking back at that what a who
the [__] was I to say that yeah I was
like 16 for like driving me into my
dishwashing job in like a 1988 Ford
Taurus that had mismatched color like
door panels on the outside that wasn't
registered and we only enough gas money
to get me to and from work we could not
drive anywhere else where we'd like run
out of gas and like we're gonna be fine
we're golden
and um no I think then for me it was
such like a vivid thing that was um like
I was like Drop Out drug dealer [__] up
and it was like no no here's how I can
do good this is being a parent yeah this
is your opportunity this is my key like
this is what's gonna like fix it and you
can maybe be a better parent that's
exactly what happened yeah
yeah clear what happened it gave you
what Focus determination yeah yeah it's
like the minute you have a child you
sort of externalize your priorities
where it's like it's not about me it's
about this like amazing thing this child
this kid but that's not the only time
that you're broke
I know it's still broke and you but then
you go on to have some success so you
move out of Connecticut success was like
there was still many years right years
and years and years away or like a
decade away because in that moment
baby's born what 97. yeah and then when
do you go live with Van
so yeah so this is like this gets a
little nuanced but like like she was
pregnant the entire time we moved to
live with Vince what happened was my
brother van was in college at William
and Marion in Virginia we lived in
Connecticut and like she and I really
started to like each other we like you
know we like We're In It Together We
didn't know she was pregnant and we like
get like let's get the [__] out of here
she got into sort of a little tiff with
her girlfriend who was the roommate and
she was like I don't want to be here
anymore and I was like I got nothing
holding me down let's go so we ran away
and we moved to Virginia where my
brother van was in college and we like
he like lived in this Flop House we had
a room in the Flop House uh he had to
adopt me my brother van oh wow yeah so
you could go to school and [__] yeah I
wasn't oh they I was only 15. yeah so
you had to adopt me that's a [__] up
story why
um well one we had we had to go in front
of a judge
he's [__] He's 21. I'm 15. we had
bleached our hair the day before
then we put hair nets over like plastic
like shower caps over yeah and we went
to Golden Corral because we were hungry
yeah but we didn't know you're not
supposed to leave it in there that long
so our [__] Scouts are bleeding and
we washed out half our hair fell out as
we go in there with like flaming red
Scouts yeah white translucent [__]
polar bear looking hair yeah and we're
wearing suits that we got at like the
thrift store like don't fit us and she's
the the judge is like what are you doing
here yeah and we had a good story which
was which was like I just want to go to
school and this is the only way I can go
to school I remember she was like all
right well I guess my better against my
better judgment
I will grant you this wow that is not
the last time again
tell that story please that one is in
the distant future but we can get to
that okay we'll get there we'll get
there okay but that's like your dad yeah
and then when we get into them did he
make you call calling dad a little bit
no that's [__] weird but oh my God
what about daddy when we got into the
park I just remember van was like
couldn't get his lighter to work and
he's like trying to get his lighter to
work to light my Winston cigarette and
he finally
got it look up and the judge is standing
there and you just lit my cigarette and
we're like thanks
and left um okay so you're living in
Virginia for a little bit and then like
and then it became like clear
like clear that she was oh yeah and it
was like you can't live in it nobody
said that to us it was like we can't
live in a [__] Flop House right
um and it was like also like ourselves
like we couldn't deny it anymore right
like we had sort of knew but it was like
the idea of someone being pregnant when
you're that young it's like unfathomable
like yeah neither of us could comprehend
that that was real yeah what's a flop
house I never heard that so I this was
literally called the hippie house and
it's no longer exists on the campus of
William and Mary but it was like a big
huge Victorian house that was kind of
[__] up but it had like 19 bedrooms in
it so everybody just chip in a couple
hundred bucks and all of a sudden you
could afford this gigantic house and
like you know the nicer the bedroom the
more expensive it was like eight people
lived in the Attic you just got like a
spot that was like 100 bucks a month and
campus on campus that's exactly what it
was yeah um it's now the university
bought it it's not like one of the
administrative buildings I went back
years ago and it was like heartbreaking
um yeah but that's where we lived okay
so you guys moved back to Connecticut we
moved in with like her cousin who had
four kids of her own very nice people
they were just looking after us we had
nowhere to live and we lived in their
basement and unfinished like concrete
basement
I remember like I remember like I got a
job washing dishes for eight bucks an
hour which was like two bucks more than
I'd ever been paid for washing dishes
yeah I remember I came home and like the
dad like her her cousins
husband he was like how did the
interview go and I was like I got the
job eight bucks an hour and I was
expecting to be like my man instead he
like I just saw the look of Terror
because he's an adult father yeah he was
like like if you work a hundred hours a
week you might be able to afford
groceries was like the look on his face
and I didn't understand that yeah but no
at eight bucks now I was like [__]
got it you never thought about selling
things
telling the song weird again you never
thought about it no no like that was no
too risky yeah and it was also just like
the the child was a it was a pivot point
it was like a psyched to like prove that
I was like good now okay so you're back
in Connecticut when do you make that
move to New York after she dumped me
which was like like we lived in a really
dumpy apartment that was dope that was
great but it was like 300 bucks a month
400 bucks a month in Connecticut in in
part of Connecticut and then I remember
we bought
some real estate
um
I was waiting for that I was like you're
just setting up the you're setting up
the pins right now I'm ready to bowl a
strike we bought a trailer yeah okay
that we were able to park on a piece of
land the trailer was twelve thousand
dollars that we were able to get a
mortgage on so our mortgage on that
trailer was like 110 a month and then to
rent the piece of land that we parked
our Caravan on was 200 bucks a month so
it cost us less monthly to live in like
a mobile home and that's where we live
yeah holy [__] and but then it meant I
could walk to work because it was closer
so you didn't have to spend any money so
we live in like this trailer park it's
like Caravan park it was not bad living
yeah but I will say like
um there's a line in Juicy about like no
heat on Christmas day like one morning
we woke up it was Christmas morning and
like the heater for our trailer had
completely fried and like we had woke up
Christmas morning it was like [__]
freezing
um but eventually she dumped me why
I mean you had so much going
I'm making eight bucks
up to like nine and change
you're on real estate she's done me for
all the right reasons okay
um and I thank the Lord every day that
she did dump me because it was the
kicking the ass that I need now I moved
in with uh the cook at the restaurant
who's also a single dad yeah I like
lived in his condo with him and then
like I started coming into New York on
Metro North to see Vans to see my
brother he this is a fun story he had to
drop out of William Mary because my
mother spent his tuition money on a new
car oh wow did you crash it I was never
allowed to drive it
um but I would have well yeah of course
um so van moved to New York City and
like New York City was like for me as a
child
like some kids had like the [__]
Testarossa or the like the Countach
poster Kathy Ireland poster I'd like the
New York City poster like I obsessed
over the city